avec le comique 19 les compagnies
pétrolières ont tout pris un coup dur
saudi aramco leader mondial du secteur
il n'y a pas échappé puisque ses
bénéfices passe à 23,2 milliards de
dollars au premier semestre
c'est moitié moins que l'an dernier à la
même période il ya quelques jours saudi
aramco a perdu sa place de 1ère sociétés
cotées au monde au profit d'apple
pourtant son entrée en bourse en
décembre dernier avait été fracassante
aramco a dépassé alibaba le spécialiste
chinois du commerce en ligne entrée en
bourse il ya quatre ans et il a même
fait mieux que les gars femmes
les revenus générés par l'entrée en
bourse de saudi aramco sont massivement
injecté dans des méga projets
d'infrastructures dans les secteurs du
tourisme et du divertissement dans
lesquelles s'est lancé le royaume sous
l'impulsion du prince héritier mohammed
bin salman vision 2030 c'est le nom de
ce programme mais ce qui devait être un
projet colossal ressemble de plus en
plus un flop mbs espérait de réaliser
l'introduction à la bourse de new york
et dans d'obtenir 100 milliards de
dollars par la vente d'actions
mais face à la froideur des
investisseurs étrangers pour un projet
aussi douteux il a obtenu finalement
beaucoup moins que ce qu'il s'était
promis pas de bourse de new york
seulement celle de ryad et des bénéfices
qui dégringole très rapidement que s'est
il passé
eh bien on peut dire que le prince
pourrait bien avoir surestimé à la fois
son projet et la confiance potentielle
d'investisseurs dans le royaume car en
vérité
investir dans le pétrole saoudien en
2020 n'est pas le plus sûr des
placements
d'un point de vue géopolitique et
idéologique l'arabie saoudite est loin
de faire l'unanimité même si mbs tente
de développer le tourisme et ouvrir peu
à peu le pays sur le monde
le chemin est encore très long plus
récemment les sordides affaires
d'exécutions de masse et l'assassinât du
journaliste jamal khashoggi ont entaché
la réputation de mohamed bin salman pour
ce qui est de la sécurité des sites
pétroliers
on se souvient des frappes du 14
septembre 2019 sur les sites de aramco
perpétrées par les rebelles houthi
preuve qu'en matière de sécurité tout
n'est pas au top ce qui peut décourager
plus d'un investisseur par ailleurs en
misant tout sur le pétrole mohammed
salman semble être allé un peu vite en
besogne avoir oublié qu'on était plus
dans les années 80 actuellement
l'économie mondiale ralentit la
consommation de pétrole dans le monde
baisse ainsi que ses prix mais surtout
les pays développés sont en plein boom
de l'écologie le but à terme est temps
de se délester de leur dépendance aux
hydrocarbures
même les constructeurs automobiles
se tournent de plus en plus vers les
véhicules électriques et d'ici une
dizaine d'année la consommation de
pétrole or a drastiquement chuté
difficile à entendre pour mbs dans le
pays repose sur sa production mais le
pétrole a de moins en moins d'avenir
aussi quel intérêt pour un investisseur
de miser massivement sur une énergie
dont l'air est bientôt révolu avec une
vente du capital bien moins importante
que prévu c'est tout le plan vision 2030
de mbs bâti financièrement sur ce projet
central qui risque d'en pâtir pourtant
lors de son accession au trône le prince
avait fait de l'entrée de l'arabie
saoudite dans l'économie moderne le
coeur de son action politique n'est pas
grand visionnaire qui veut